the economy is pretty tough these days
prices on everything going through the
roof inflation is up
i think i have identified the most
lucrative career out there and that
would be race hustling man things have
never been better for race hustlers than
they are right now you see a ton of them
cropping up so i
am now going to give you the definitive
answer on the top dog race hustler
around there's a lot of competition out
there the producers have put it together
into a showdown
let's get started
we've got oh this is a true veteran of
race hustling one of the og's of my
lifetime at least obviously the process
is going on a long long time the game's
been around a lot longer than i have al
sharpton
al sharpton who i like how they have to
use
you know vague language or they say he
was accused of inciting the crown
heights riot yeah yeah no accused
there's allegedly yeah so he incites the
crown heights riot in 1991 he's the
founder of his extortion group he's the
founder of his bank account the national
action network and he spells a respect
r-e-s-p-i-c-t
show some r-e-s-p-i-c-t
respect
al sharpton okay i mean he
he it's hard to imagine that someone's
gonna outdo sharpton who's next
sir i don't even i don't even think i've
heard of this guy sir major page
is that michael avenatti i'm always
putting on the handcuffs oh
is that just michael avenatti in
disguise
this is a new hustle because nike didn't
work out he wasn't able to to get
millions out of nike so now he's just
pretending to i guess he's pretending to
be a black guy he's a creator of of
black lives matter of greater atlanta uh
raised 450 000 in donations following
the death of george floyd now he's
federally charged with wire fraud and
money laundering after blowing donation
money on hookers and guns
so he
this guy looks white to me
he which might be part of the hustle i i
guess it could be mixed race i don't
know that's a lot of times when race
hustlers get called out for pretending
to be black when they're not sometimes
they'll say well i'm mixed race and
maybe they are maybe he's mixed race i
don't know it's sometimes hard to tell
but uh it's even funnier if he's a white
guy but i'm gonna have to give this one
to to al sharpton
because this is the this is much more
outrageous obviously but one the fact
that i haven't heard of this guy i think
shows you he's not as successful and the
fact that he's now getting in trouble
for misusing his
donations raised shows you that he's
just not as good at race hustling al
sharpton's blown a lot of money too i
don't know if it was on hookers and guns
but certainly on nice suits private air
travel you know al sharpton's lived a
pretty good life
either exploiting tragedies or
completely making them up out of nowhere
so anyway i'm gonna give it to
al sharpton no question let's keep going
speaking of white people pretending to
be black rachel dolezal rachel dolezal a
white woman who pretended to be black
she then became this is like a chapel
show skit
she became the
president of a chapter of the naacp
uh then she was charged with a couple of
felonies including welfare fraud
uh rachel dolezal also
was sending threats to herself i think
and she as they say essentially did
blackface every day for years i i do
have a bit of pity for rachel dallas
although because
we are told today that if a man says
that he's a woman and he really believes
himself to be a woman or he really wants
to be then he just is a woman and and if
you question that you're a bigot and
you're awful and you're terrible so
rachel dallas all just did this with
race and now she's called a terrible
awful horrible bigot rachel dolezal's
trans racialism is way less ridiculous
than transgenderism because race is far
less important as a as a distinction
among human beings than sex is i don't
know what you're implying rachel dolezal
has a great deal of my sympathy who's
against her
patrice oh yeah patrice callers
co-founder of blm hardcore actual
marxist pretty intelligent woman too
she founded blm which people think means
black lives matter actually though we
recently found out it means buy large
mansions she got in trouble because she
bought four homes worth about four
million bucks a lot of them in la really
nice neighborhoods not exactly living in
the ghetto okay she was living
living in pretty posh places
this one's not even hard patrice colors
patrice culler she's the real deal man i
mean she's an actual marxist she's
trying to undo western civilization she
admits that she when she was called to
marxist she doubled down on it i do
believe in marxism they've caused a lot
of damage i mean their their ideology
has rewritten american history so she
she totally wins that one no doubt
oh here he is the man
the man who started the most recent
spate of
of race hustling identity colin
kaepernick
as you know started kneeling for the
anthem
in the nfl after oh i actually didn't i
don't watch the nfl i certainly had
never heard of kaepernick before he
cashed in on being a race hustler but
but i guess he had lost the starting
quarterback role so then he started
complaining and whining and crying and
saying america's terrible he wore socks
at a san francisco open practice that
portrayed the cops as pigs yeah he uh
complains about oppression even though
he's made zillions of dollars through
endorsements i mean there's no question
the man is is many many multitudes if
not an order of magnitude richer
as a result of his
not being a starting quarterback uh
then than he would have been had he just
had a normal regular nfl career
he also i think he wasn't he raised by
white parents what he's awful i mean
he's truly a disgrace if i could banish
him to saint helena i would who's he
against
oh wow this okay this is the first one
that's actually kind of tough robin
deangelo she is awful the white author
well are italians white i don't know
it's a question it's always a question
uh she's the author of white fragility
works in critical discourse analysis
whatever okay and whiteness studies you
know those totally real academic fields
not just absolute babble gobbledygook
nonsense for mediocrities who can't
actually
study a real subject in school
she was caught encouraging coca-cola
employees to try to be less white yeah i
oh this is really tough
i'm going to actually have to give this
one to robin deangelo
because they're both opportunists who
have enriched themselves on racial
division
and i suspect kaepernick's enriched
himself even more than deangelo has she
has this kind of influence over the
conversation and she's got i think much
more of an influence in corporate
america kaepernick
cashed in on nike but but robin deangelo
was cashing in on basically every
company in america including coca-cola
so i i think doctor dr robin diet like
dr joe biden dr robin d'angelo uh she
she takes the cake i think
sean king okay sean king this is another
guy who was accused of being white
because his birth certificate says his
parents are white
and then his disgusting response to that
was basically to say that his his mother
had loose morals and cheated on his dad
not a great guy
named one of time magazine's 25 most
influential people on the internet
in 2018 i think he's kind of declined
his current oh you're kidding
he's a writer in residence at harvard
law school
could this guy string an english
sentence together he's at harvard law
school's fair punishment project
confirms so much of what i've thought
about harvard my whole life
and uh yes as as i mentioned has white
man on his birth certificate okay so
he's sean king he's just made a career
you know he didn't have a particularly
promising career doing anything else so
he made a career
uh either exploiting or or inventing
racial incidents
who's he against
ibrahim can be yeah
he's the director for anti-racist
research
at boston university he's the author of
anti-racist baby
that's my nickname by the way that's
what that's what the girls would call me
in high school and college they're like
oh hey what's going on anti-racist baby
oh nothing girl what's going on sugar uh
his real name is ibram henry rogers and
he's been a vegan since at least 2015.
yeah didn't he took his wife's name or
he and his wife invented a new name or
something
yeah this one's not hard either it's the
difference between
the the street peddler and the head of
the cartel all right
he wins
all right this is the semi-final round
when we start with sharpton okay
sharpton vs patrice colors this woman
you know led an organization that burned
the country down in 2020 and she still
has politicians kissing up to her her
now the problem with colors is that she
this actually might change my
this might change my calculus because
colors did have to leave she had to
resign from blm
because she got caught in that financial
scam
i'm giving this one to al sharpton
because he's had a lot of financial
scandals too
but he's he survived
he survived the men she has now remains
to be seen if she can resurrect her
career so i'm actually going to give
this one to al sharpton okay then we got
robin d'angelo versus ibram kendy oh man
it's like the spider-man meme it's like
you know you no i mean it's truly
arsenic and cyanide
deangelo versus candy gosh they're like
the same person
[Music]
i'm gonna have to give this one to
to deangelo i
i think i'm gonna have to give this
because they both peddle the same trash
and they're both
push nonsense pedal nonsense but i think
d'angelo has had a greater influence in
the corporate sphere than candy has
and it's also just
there's something particularly clever
and perverse about this white woman
selling white self-hatred it's really
talk about a niche
field so i'm gonna give that one to
d'angelo all right so now we're down to
the final round gosh
al sharpton versus robin d'angelo okay
here i think the logic i was going to
apply to
patrice colors i think i'm going to have
to apply this here to robin d'angelo
al sharpton
sharpton has basically been put out to
pasture at this point
he still shows up where he thinks he can
make a buck and he puts his face on
camera and he very often just makes up
racial incidents or he defends criminals
just in case if they're black and the
cop or whoever shot them is white he'll
defend even vicious vile criminals
sometimes but but at this point his
heart's not in it he's not really in the
national conversation whereas robin
d'angelo is still in many ways directing
the national conversation
so she wins the white lady wins again
maybe this is blue maybe this is maybe
it's not a hustle maybe it's maybe this
is oppression
i don't know let me know if you agree in
the comments with my pick for the worst
the top dog race hustler
and any other race hustling candidate
that you think ought to have a shot at
the title we'll see you next time show
some r-e-s-p-i-c-t
[Music]
[Music]
you